how do we develop a capacity to
represent something if the signed
vehicle we're using has no relationship
to what it represents that's the
language problem
um and for years and this begins I I
would say hundreds of years back in time
um we've just sort of assumed that well
this is just a convention we just agree
that it does
um the problem is the conventions just
don't happen by accident
problem is
um yes a miracle could happen and give
us language
and allow us to have all the same ways
of doing it
or
like any other convention any other
social habit it takes communication to
set it up
so think about any other thing that we
agree upon
to do a habit that we have socially
um to establish that convention we have
to communicate about it
now that means you can't use a
convention to produce a convention
unless you already have a first
convention how do you get the first one
how do you get language when there's no
language when there's no other
conventional form of communication
and that is just watch young children
they
recognize things that are like each
other
they communicate to others by sharing
objects of a certain kind they point or
reach that is pointing is an index
objects that you can play with or food
that's that's always food or drink
that's always drink there each instance
is Iconic of each other
so right away children are born like
other species with lots of iconic and
indexical capacity
and as the first year goes by and they
develop this unique way of indicating
that only we humans have which is
pointing with our fingers and hands
and looking in particular directions and
watching somebody else's gaze these are
all indices
they're directly correlated with
something that's there
so children build up this
conventionality
um slowly in the first year of Life they
have lots of information about
Communication in order to build up a
means of communicating that lacks that
in other words to develop the
conventionality they also have to they
have to use iconic and indexical
abilities
so one of the real challenges in
understanding the brain then is first of
all to understand that that whenever you
build up conventional communication I
like to call this displaced reference
it's because nothing about the sign
vehicle give it gives it away it's only
the sharing of of interpretive
capacities it gives it makes it work
um to share it of course we have to we
have to go through all of these
processes we're really good at it
um
my work has begun to pursue this even at
the molecular level we were just talking
about bacteria a minute ago but it turns
out that we see the same thing going on
even at the molecular level think about
the simple example of
how DNA produces proteins that have
interesting three-dimensional structures
um DNA has a sequence of nucleotides
every three of them we call a codon it's
interesting we use the the metaphor of a
code here think about Morse code Morse
code is an arbitrary correlation between
dots and dashes and letters
um two conventions
and we've now linked them together with
a conventional Association because dots
and dashes aren't letters
um so we have exactly the kind of thing
that we're struggling with here a
conventional or symbolic form of
communication
um
a codon
matches to an anticodon in a messenger
RNA molecule
so that in going from DNA to the
messenger RNA it's laid out in iconic
ways
that is the
messenger RNA now is a reflection of an
exact you know reverse isomorphism of
the DNA that took that information from
its nucleotide sequence corresponds
exactly to the one that's produced by
the DNA molecule
then taken into a ribosome that
structure also made up of DNA I mean of
RNA and protein
um then takes in another kind of RNA
molecule Transfer RNA molecule which has
on one end of it
um three nucleotides which will match
again in anti what we call anticodon
fashion that is the reverse three that
now attaches it iconically to the
messenger RNA molecule
but on the other end of the transfer arm
why is it iconically attaches oh because
it's it's a mirror image
so it has all so we might say it
co-varies it's a covariance relationship
um and what we mean by if there's a
similarity in this case
um there's an inverse similarity so in
the DNA molecule the A's G C's and T's
um uh match up with
they're opposite so G and C you know
bind together a and t bind together uh
in the messenger RNA
um you replace one of them with another
one called uracil
um which is a slightly slightly related
uh nucleotide and then so now we've got
three things that bind together I'll say
only do it by by showing so you got RNA
molecule binding to the DNA molecule
it's now carries a mirror image in fact
it's up it's opposite side would be the
DNA molecule but now it then carries
over and binds to here I've got my RNA
molecule coming across here and it binds
to
um another RNA molecule the transfer RNA
molecule
um so that the the three bases in the
DNA molecule mapped to three bases in
the RNA mole in messenger RNA molecule
which may up to three bases in the
transfer RNA molecule which is now since
this is the the reverse the mirror image
now it binds again and you've got the
original image back
so what you have is you've maintained
the form
the form or what I would call the
constraint the sequence constraint has
been maintained so we would say that by
covariance relationship information has
been transferred okay okay so constraint
is the same as information in this case
or no so all I'm going to show you is is
how they're this the same but it turns
out there's a hierarchic relationship
that we have to keep in in mind in order
to show this this was lost in
information Theory originally in the
1940s and 50s and it needs to be brought
back and I'll explain why in a minute
but the idea is that so now there's a
covariance relationship we've passed
this covariance
from one molecule to another molecule to
a third molecule that transfer RNA
molecule has also got at the other end
of it an amino acid and each three
codons on one end is matched to a
specific amino acid on the other end
that amino acid is now brought together
these three attached to the next three
to the next three different amino acids
correspond to the different codon
and now by bringing together
um different Transfer RNA molecules
you're also bringing together
different
amino acids
so that now what's happening there's a
continuity relationship or a correlation
relationship
that correlation relationship is now
also correlating amino acids which tend
to get stuck together and they produce a
long string of amino acids that is coded
for in the sequence in the DNA molecule
so now we have gone from a DNA molecule
by a covariance relationship and to the
RNA molecule which has a correlational
relationship and neighboring Transfer
RNA molecules now provide amino acids
with a correlational relationship so by
virtue of taking
um similarity relationship covariance
relationship and then a correlation
relationship we've now allowed DNA
molecule which has no relationship to
proteins as as molecules proteins are
made up of totally different molecules
in a string that tend to fold up because
of their electrical and hydrophobic and
hydrophilic potentials into
three-dimensional structures
that linear structure has passed its
information on through these multiple
steps to a totally different kind of
molecule
which can now interact with other
proteins and other kinds of molecules to
produce most of the work of the cell
what's happened is the reason we call
this a codon relationship is there's a
code-like relationship between them that
is what we've done is we figured out in
biology now Evolution has figured this
out so to speak
um how to take a linear relationship in
one kind of molecule and create a
particular kind of three-dimensional
molecule made up of totally different
kinds of atoms that is made up of amino
acids as opposed to nuclei nucleotides
and
its function is determined by its
three-dimensional structure by how it's
folded
so in effect there's almost no
relationship between them you would this
is why thinking of it as a code it's not
crazy it's it's arbitrary
and yet the arbitrarity has been
produced by this multi-step process that
links covariance with correlation
in a way that allows this to happen that
I like to call covariance relationships
and correlation relationships grounded
they're grounded because the vehicle
that carries it is carrying some feature
in common with what it represents with
the information that it's carrying so if
it's a likeness relation if it's a
covariant covariance relationship it's
carrying some kind of formal feature
forward into another kind of molecule
whereas if it's just physically
correlated struck together
not by virtue of likeness but by simply
by virtue of being next to each other
being correlated being attached
um that also is grounded physically
grounded one is formally grounded and
one is physically grounded okay but by
stacking one on top of the other it now
produces the kind of distance between
where you started and where you end so
that now there's a what I call displaced
reference the information in the DNA
molecule is there in the protein but in
a totally different form
there's been a continuity of information
transfer but a complete loss of
groundedness
at the physical level and yet there's an
informational ground in this because
you've transferred
the same correlations
as a result there can be selection that
affects proteins and how they interact
and that'll select for particular
sequences of genes that produce those
useful proteins even though they're
totally separate kinds of molecules
it adds one further feature that I think
is also important to think about it in
terms of the mathematics of all of this
that is the protein now has a
three-dimensional structure but DNA also
has a three-dimensional structure it's
twist and its twist is slightly
different depending on which
nucleotides are in that sequence
now my watch is talking to me just a
minute it's all right repeat that last
part the DNA so the DNA sequence is of
nucleotides but it turns out that we we
think about the DNA molecule as as a
Twist as a helix it turns out that the
Helix is slightly differently Twisted
depending on the sequence
so it's not a uniform twist all the way
up so depending on the actual rung in
the ladder or depending on a sequence of
rungs no depending on the sequence of
Rooks the sequence of rungs make it
tight more tightly twisted or more
Loosely twisted depending on what the
sequence is and that means that there's
a three-dimensional structure to the DNA
molecule so it turns out that there are
some proteins that are produced produced
by virtue of being you know the
information taken off of the DNA
molecule that are structured in such a
way that they can bind into the twist so
there's information that's passed from
the DNA to the protein and then there's
also structural information in terms of
the zeros and ones that we ordinarily
think of so those are the rungs and then
there's also structural information in
the sense that certain sequences of
those zeros and ones physically produce
a different structure in the DNA and
right it's not to say necessarily that
the protein then copies that but it
somehow relates no no the proteins don't
copy they want to be clear what this
says is that because
the protein molecule is a totally
different kind of molecule but it has
three-dimensional shape
what that means is that some proteins we
call them transcription factors
actually bind to DNA by fitting with a
Twist
and since that twist is determined by
the sequence
then what's happened is that the
proteins identify a region of the DNA
molecule
and as a result those proteins can play
a role in up regulating or down
regulating the expression
of genes
so now you have recursion possible
so what's happened by virtue of this
displacement from one kind of
information that is sequence information
zero and one information you might think
about it two three-dimensional physical
information
because they are both embodied
physically
they're capable of interacting but now
on a totally different basis
now the protein can regulate the DNA
that produces proteins
by virtue of this displacement of
reference
it's possible to now have that displaced
molecule regulate the kind of molecule
that produced it
this is recursion but notice that this
is a kind of interesting recursion it's
very similar to the gerdelion recursion
but you need to have even a simple
Paradox like a liar's Paradox is that
you can't stop interpreting because it
refers to itself the liar is a paradox
the simplest one is of course this
statement is a lie or this statement is
false
um once you interpret it you have to
reapply it back to the statement
originally you can't stop interpreting
because if it's a lie then it must it
must not be true but if it must not be
true then it's a lie that's a lie so it
must be true the classic the classic
circularity here this is the basis in a
much more complicated version of
girdle's incompleteness proof for
mathematics
um that is basically you have to have
some way that something can refer to
itself it has to have this kind of
recursion
the point here is that that recursion is
possible with DNA and proteins because
of this displacement
DNA and RNA have to be linked to each
other by likeness relationships
um but DNA and proteins have totally
different reasons for having the
physical structures they they have but
as a result now you can have DNA
modified DNA indirectly through proteins
this hierarchy of communication in very
simple genetics is what makes possible
the complexity of bodies and cells
you've got to have this kind of
recursion because now the DNA can play a
role through Communications through
other interactions with the cell because
the proteins are now carrying
information also about their interaction
with other proteins maybe even with the
world that information can now modify
how genes produce and expressed
um so the complexity becomes possible
people in semiotics have talked about
this as scaffolding that is you're
building up new levels of information
that can now be a basis for building up
yet higher order information
so in fact this relationship I've just
talked about is what makes it possible
to have
um
complicated multi-celled bodies that
have repeated Parts think about the
multiple legs on insects or the multiple
ribs or the multiple vertebrae in our
bodies this is the result of exactly
this kind of transcription Factor effect
that is proteins that produce genes that
modify other genes well it turns out
that that with by a series of other
features
um genes have duplicated and varied and
you're producing this in a sort of theme
and variation fashion once you have
recursion you can do sort of theme
variation effects
um higher order effects and this is what
produces the sort of the what you might
call the theme and variation repeated
bodily parts that makes plants and
animals possible
so in effect what I became very
interested in and this is really uh
by the end of the 1990s
was not only that I'm finding that
there's a lot of
um
indirect causality that makes this
possible in the brain and how it must
have been possible neurologically but it
now tells me that there's a way that
this is relevant to biology and maybe
something as universal as mathematics
itself that this same hierarchical
relationship how you get recursion how
you make recursion possible
um has to do with this what I call I I
describe this sort of characteristically
as one two three repeat
one
the iconicity that is the co-variation
okay two
correlation physical correlation in some
respects and three displacement
once you've displaced you can now go
back and have that displaced reference
modify one
two three repeat
um is giving you this this capacity for
recursion
now one of the things that I realized at
this point is that it also helped me
understand why Noam Chomsky and I were
having so much trouble agreeing about
um what are you called Universal grammar
when I wrote in the mid-1990s about the
evolution of language mostly from the
point of view of what's changed in the
brain
um I was saying that look
um Universal grammar has a genetically
predisposed feature is
evolutionarily essentially impossible
it's impossible for the same reason that
we don't have innate words
for something to be selected in the
course of evolution it has to first of
all be consistently repeated again and
again and again in the world
its relationship to something that's
relevant to life has to also be a strong
correlation
it's got to have these same features
repeat it again and again and again
that's iconic
um having a correlation with something
relevant like survival value food
Predator defense whatever
um that's a physical correlation that
has to be there true
but then to develop the evolution of
this this selection has to be repeated
again and again and the substrate in the
body
that's now going to put those together
to hold them together that is the
adaptation
um has to be produced by this recursive
process happening again and again in the
course of evolution
words for example the reason we don't
have innate words
is simple
and that is words change their meaning
pretty rapidly
um they don't persist generation upon
generation for thousands of years in
just a thousand of years Thousand Years
a language that has split can become
totally non-intertranslatable
and we've seen that of course in the
history of Europe for the most part
um but the same thing is true in
evolution but much much larger there's
the constancy must go on for hundreds of
generations to really make a dent in the
biology of the organism
so words of course don't have this
feature they change too fast their
association with things in the world is
too fleeting and flexible and finally
they don't have much of a reproductive
consequence
in order for mutations to have any kind
of effect at all they have to be the
same over and over and over again and
they have to have a reproductive
consequence words don't have this and so
we have to learn words socially we have
to trans transmit them from person to
person from so from in social groups in
fact you have to have a larger social
group to remember all that information
to hold it collectively
um now think about grammar
grammar is even more abstract than words
grammar has fewer constraints in part
because it's not directly correlated
with things in the world at least my
word dog and my word drink I have
something physically correlated in the
world it's just not very stable and
regular
over the course of evolutionary time
when you said the word dog that's
symbolic and when you went like this
drink that's symbolic but also indexical
because you showed something
exactly and I'm gonna this is what's
gonna get us back to finally back to
syntax
um why I think
um
After Reading Writing the theme box I
just want to make it clear syntax is a
synonym for grammar in this case
grammar and so syntax just refers mostly
to relative positions of things uh in a
sequence so we can talk about the syntax
of uh of symbols in a mathematical
equation
and how you have to the syntax is how
you have to move them around who can be
next to who who can't be next to who who
can modify who and so on what
constitutes a well-formed sentence yeah
exactly okay so grammar is the specific
kind of constraints on that
that language has
so grammar can tell you there's certain
kinds of words that are content words
certain kinds of words that play the
role of a of a verb or a noun or a
pronoun uh because of their kind they
have to be connected with other words in
a particular way
you can't just randomly throw words
together and have them work
they have to have both a sequence that's
maybe characteristically different in
different languages
but most languages have words that play
the role of a verb or a noun for example
those are chomsky's universals
and there are many of them Chomsky talks
about lots of syntactical operations
that are that he says are going to be
Universal around the world he he
developed this interestingly enough in
the nineteen early late 1950s early
1960s
um
by virtue of his knowledge
um of something else that I thought was
just just brilliant about his his
realization back then which was
um comparing how you analyze grammar and
syntax to a turing machine you just
watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video